okay so here's another question without
words but just like you might have been
able to see with earlier ones the
question is implied as what is the
Shaded area so um this is a square and
you can see that because
um quadrilateral all the sides are equal
so it's a rhombus at least but once you
pop a right angle in the corner there
that defines it that locks it in as a
square okay
so in order to work out this area half
of the square evidently the side lengths
are going to be important but in case
you haven't worked this out already uh
you know the the avenue to get to the
side length to relate the six and the
three and the four to that we're going
to need some right angle triangle
somewhere
um the the abundant number of right
angles that you can see here and here
might have clued you into that but the
question Still Remains how can you form
triangles that are going to help you
here in order to get from the six and
the three and the four which are the
only measurements you know
and then relate that to the diagonal
which is then going to be related to the
the side lengths okay so how are we
going to go about this just like before
if you haven't already pause the video
give it a whirl but uh for me the the
thing that sort of cracked this apart
was
to recognize that the diagonal that has
been shown here the diagonal here is
equal in length to the diagonal from the
other side right this is one of the
properties of a rectangle and all
squares are rectangles that both
diagonals have to be equal to each other
so knowing that I can find what this um
if I can find this diagonal I'm done
right how does this diagonal here I
might put in what's a what's a good
color let's choose something like
maybe a Maybe Pink would do it because I
want it to stand out
against the blue and the white okay
there you go hopefully you can see that
all right this diagonal here if I can
work out what that is then I'm pretty
much done right so you can see I'm kind
of trying to reverse engineer the
question I know I'm headed towards an
area and to do that I need side length
that's related to the hypotenuse the
diagonal here's a diagonal that's more
closely related to the six and the three
and the four okay all right so at this
point I'm going to assume you've paused
and tried it if you were going to pause
and try it I'm going to spoil it now
okay
this pink diagonal of the square is not
just a diagonal of this Square it is
also the diagonal of a different shape
that isn't drawn in and that's part of
what's problematic here you've seen most
of the questions we've been doing here
constructions are involved and so seeing
where you need to place constructions is
often part of the problem okay so what
is the other shape in which this pink
diagonal also sits well I'm going to
extend you see these sort of awkward not
quiet diagonals here that are sort of
running but then they stop Midway from
the corner upwards and then from the
corner downwards what I'm going to do is
I'm going to extend them out so if I
just sort of keep on going
like so just just draw all the way there
and then I'll do the same thing from the
opposite corner so I'm just going to
extend or I think they often call this
producing the line there all right that
looks pretty lined up to me
I wonder if it's a bit clearer to you
yet if it's not quite obvious I'm going
to put one more Construction in which is
you can see I've so far extended these
six and four centimeter lengths now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to create
lines that are parallel to this three
centimeter length here but that go
through these two corners right so if I
do that here
you can see in fact what I'll do is I'll
just draw this length in here
so that I know it's going to be parallel
as I move it I'm going to move one over
here
and then I'm also going to move one down
here and it looks like I overshot
this a little bit here so let's just
delete that off the end there
a bit more there we go all right so what
have I got now well if you zoom out just
a little bit right you can see remember
I mentioned the pink diagonal of the
square is also a pink diagonal of this
new rectangle that I've drawn and what's
great about this rectangle is you
actually know a fair bit about it for
starters
you know uh let's stay with pink because
I started using it right you know what
this length all the way up and down is
because it's comprised of the six and
the four so this is going to be 10
centimeters right
and then if you have a look at this this
perpendicular length over here you can
see that it must be equal to that three
that's in the middle now if you are
paying cost attention you might be
saying how did I know that this this new
shape here that I've drawn all the way
around how did I know it was going to be
a rectangle I just want you to think
about the way that I created it right
number one I produced this length here
so this length this entire length here
is parallel to the four and then this
entire link here is parallel to the six
but the six and the four are both
mutually at right angles to this three
and the the opposite ends let me just
highlight it for you the opposite ends
here and here are parallel to that three
I probably should have just marked that
in as parallel that's what a trained
professional would have done so because
you got these parallel lines
you also know that the right angles here
um imply right angles here in the
corners so that's how I know this is a
rectangle and that's what allows me to
use Pythagoras Theorem because uh maybe
I can do it like so in fact I'm gonna
I'm gonna steal a triangle from up here
let's see if this will do the drum for
me
there we go if I paste this in here put
these in some appropriate corners
like so well you can't see that color at
all okay you're going over the blue I
wonder why it's going underneath the
picture it's not very helpful
um but anyway I think you can still see
roughly what's going on here you can see
that this is the right angle triangle
that's been created here I might get a
rid of these highlightings so you can
see a bit more clearer actually you know
what I'll make it like really really
Ultra obvious let's just go right over
the top there
this is the right angle triangle in
question
I know what this length here is it's 10
I know what this length here is 3 and
then that will give me this diagonal so
since it's a diagonal let's call it D
for diagonal in centimeters okay so
that's all of the geometric thinking now
let's actually start crunching the
numbers and see what we end up with
so because it's the hypotenuse it's uh
oops it easy it's equal to the sum of
the squares of the shorter sides so that
is going to be well 9 plus 100 is just a
hundred and nine so that diagonal there
this one that I drew in pink is the same
as this diagonal here and what that can
help me work out is if this is uh the
side length of the square it's also the
side length over here so in a new right
angle triangle the blue one right the
one that I'm actually interested in I
can say the sum of the squares is equal
to the hypotenuse because it's the same
hypotenuse I saw before
so I've got 2s squared is equal to 109
there's just a straight substitution
happening there from my earlier equation
at the top and so s squared is that
divided by two
so now to finish I can say the blue area
is well it's just a triangle so it's
half base times height in this case the
base and the height have a look the base
is s and the height for the
perpendicular height I should say is
also s so therefore this is going to be
just half s squared I just said what s
squared was it was
109 on two so this is 109 on 4 square
centimeters and you can see that's the
same as what's that 27 and a quarter
square centimeters if you want to write
it as a mixed numeral